المزيد نورنا من بيروت الفنانه الجميله
ولاء الجندي يسعد صباحك يا ولاء نورتنا في
صباح العربيه شكرا على تواجدك معانا السنه
الجديده
[موسيقى]
يا هلا فيك يا هلا فيك صباح الخير وصباح
النور والفل لكل اللي عم يسمعونا
ولحضراتكم كمان انا كثير مبسوط انا موجوده
معكم اليوم همم وان شاء الله يا رب هالسنه
بتكون سنه خير علينا وعليكم وعلى كل اللي
عم يسمعنا كمان يا رب على الجميع
[موسيقى]
طبعا احنا تربينا على على الزمن الجميل
تربينا على المغنى المظبوط وعلى الاغاني
يعني اللي فيها هيك حب وفيها مشاعر وفيها
مسيئه وفيها يعني حدا بنبسط لما يسمع
فمن انا وصغيره يعني تربيت على هذا الشيء
وبقى معي لحتى يعني صرت بالسنويه وصرت
بايام الجامعه وحبيت تكفي بهذه القصص باول
مشوار كانت ذا فويس والحمد لله هلا يعني
وصلنا
وما فيها اكثر من هيك نكون مبسوطين الحمد
لله
هذه الاغنيه اعطينا التفاصيل هذه اللحظات
وكيف كان شعورك وقتها
طبعا كانت من احلى
يعني احلى احساس ممكن حدا يحسوا خصوصي بعد
ما يعني ربحنا جائزه الامير عبد الله
الفيصل للقصيده المغنث باغنيه لناس لكم
فرده فعل همم سمو الامير خالد كانت يعني
هيك ااه بتعطي للفنان حماس اكثر انه سابر
على هذا الشيء اللي عم يقدمه همم نبقى
دائما موجودين بهذا الخط اللي عم بنمشي
ونقدم للناس يعني قصائد وكلمات حلوه ولحن
حلو ومغنى حلو يعني اذا بدكم طيب خلينا
نسمعها يا ولاء
اكيد طبعا
تفضلي
[موسيقى]
والله
لن
اسلكوموه حتى وان سلوت
موه او انكم
نسيتوه عهدا لنا قطعت
[موسيقى]
والزمان قطع
عليا اوه عليكم
او الليالي
غيبت
احلى منال ينعن
عمود
[موسيقى]
متهيا له
ايوه البالي ومن
بالحب بات يحلم
وخال
من بالحب بات يحلم الله عليك يا ولاء الله
الله يحميلك هالصوت طيب ولاء معروفه في
الوسط الفني انك تختارينا بعنايه ماذا
تغنين كيف تختارين يا ولاء ولمن تفضلين
الغناء
طبعا انا يعني اصدرت البوم مؤخرا مش من
سنه يعتبر همم من ست اغاني ايه للشاعر عبد
العزيز سعود البطين الشعاع الكويتي وايضا
من كلمات الدكتوره منى الساحلي
فا اكيد لما نختار القصائد اكيد بيكون عم
نقرا عده اشعار بنختار منهن الانسب
للتلحين والانسب ليكون مقفى اكثر وهيك
فاكيد طبعا
بالتعاون مع الملحن نعرض عليه كذا ناس
وبشوف الملحن حسب شو هو حاس اكثر حتى يطلع
معهن لحاله ويطلع يعني نصف الاحساس مضبوط
للمستعمل طيب ولا انا عندي فضول كيف لغتك
العربيه الفصحى لانه الاغاني مش بس موسيقى
ولحم وصوت طلبي كمان في مخارج حروف وخصوصا
انك عم تغني قصائد شعريه بالعربيه الفصحى
صحيح طبعا هذا السؤال دايما بيسالوني اياه
والجواب هو الوحيد انه نحنا ربينا على
قراءه القران الكريم وكان جدي حتى يعني
كان منشد وقارئ القران وكان دائما
بالجلسات والاعداد سوا كان يعلمني المخارج
كيف اللفظ الصحيح كيف اكيد هذا الشيء باثر
حاليا
خصوصا التربيه لكن لماذا اغنياتك يعني حتى
الان لازاله قليله يعني ليست بالعدد
المطلوب
[موسيقى]
طبعا الاغنيه الواحده من الاغاني يعني من
الالبوم الاغنيه الواحده تعتبر بدها شغل
كثير غير عن الاغاني اليوم الموجوده
السريعه عندك لانه بتعرفي انه القصائد او
الموسيقى العربيه اللي عم بستخدمه انا
بالقصائد عم تكون متنوعه بالمقامات
الموسيقيه وحتى بالايقاعات فهذا الشيء بده
وقت طويل حتى ينعطها حقه للاغنيه ونعطي
يعني موسيقه تكون لايقه على القصيده وبنفس
الوقت حتى نقدر نطوع القصيده حتى تكون
سهله للمستمع اكثر همم من انه تكون بس لحن
معقد يعني انا برد على السهام كمان اسمحي
لي اجاوب عنك اقول مش مهم العدد المهم
النوعيه على كل حال ولا لا بما انه نحن في
الصباح لكن حابين نسمع يا صبري الليل ههه
يا صبري الليل
معانا نحنا هلا فايقين بعدنا يعني عرفت
المقصود بعد ما بيكون محمد
يا صبر الليل متى غدوه
قضاء العمري وجددوا
واقضي العمر
ويبعدوني مروا الاعوام
ويبعده
فدوى قلبي
بتجلده
وحبيب العشق
يخلدوني
[موسيقى]
وفؤاد
يشرده
فدوى قلبي
بتجلده
وحبيب العشق
يخلدون
اتابعون
وفؤاد النميل يشار
تحدث الان عن مشاريعك الجديده وبماذا
تعيدين جمهورك الذي يحبك
ااه ان شاء الله همم
الخميس هذا الخميس ان شاء الله راح تنزل
قصيده جديده
واغنيه لولاء الجندي كمان جديده تعتبر
يعني من الاغاني الشوي هيك يعني همم جربنا
اكثر نروح للناس نروح للجمهور حتى نوسع
اكثر همم جمهور حتى يرجع يسمع القصائد
ويرجع يسمع الموسيقى
المتعلقه بالقائد راح تكون من الحان همم
الملحن اللبناني صلاح الكردي وطبعا من
كلمات الشاعر عبد العزيز البطين وان شاء
الله يا رب هيك بتلقى النجاح
وصدى صدى كبير باذن الله بالتوفيق دايما
يا ولاء همم وصفك انه قد بانه اغاني
كتلامس الفن الراقي اليوم ولا ممكن نشوفها
بالصوره ثانيه وبطريقه راقيه ايضا ولكن
مثلا اغاني تلامس اكثر عامه شعبيه اكثر
هلا اكيد ما في شيء بيمنع انه نحن مجرب
بالطبيع يعني الحال كل فنان بيحب يغني
بلغه بلده بلهجه بلده فممكن اكيد طبعا يوم
القيامه ارجع اغني شيء باللبناني حتى شيء
بالمصري او شيء بالخليجي يعني مش اي شيء
يعتبر بالعكس اي فن بتقدم اليوم وفين نحنا
نحترمه اكيد وبنقره وكل حدا بينجح بمجال
همم محدد بالفن الحمد لله مشيت مشيت بهذا
المجال ان شاء الله نقدر نكمل للاخر اكيد
ومثل ما خبرتك انه ممكن كثير يعني نقدم اي
شيء بالعاميه طيب ولاء في هيك شغله على
بالك تسمعينا اياها انه برده تكون هيك
بالعاميه قريبه على قلبك
ده العميه اييه طبعا فينا نغني شيله فيروز
اذا بدك احلى
يلا رح نقول مقطع من عز النوم
من عز النوم
بتسرقني بهرب
لبعيد تسبقني من عز النوم بتسرق
بهار
وبلبعيد بتسبقني يا حبي صرت باخر
عطيه وتمشي في الارض لو عينك بعدك لاحقني
الله الله عليك يا ولاء شكرا